okay I'm gonna give you a clue from
Pat's Christmas that is the right person
right scooby-doo
no is the movie corny often is it moving
in the most basic more I can't do it in
the most basic moral way every year we
watch it Love Actually that's it guys
classic classic moral tale this man
watch is right here it's got it's at the
start of the name the name of the movie
begins wonderful Christmas
it's one of life oh you just wasted on
the wrong rented on Christmas Eve and
give that Wonderful Life [ __ ] a rest for
one year Oh Bad Santa
oh you're terrible at this game
die hard it's right isn't it isn't right
yippee-ki-yay mother [ __ ] one of the
tool man's best forays into film two men
okay I'm gonna give you a clue on Pat's
Christmas hmm that is the right person
Ruby do know the TV show that begins
with oh we had like four sons and
there's the neighbor with the fence and
he's like oh hey exactly so who's the
lead actor he did a Christmas movie by
Tim Curtin Abdul yeah Tim you did a
Christmas movie what is it called oh my
god I don't know the name oh well what
is father Christmas often known as what
sequel roars sorry boys
so put V in front of that the Santa
Claus well done Hey look I am lactose
intolerant and I am just about this
close to taking all those presents back
up the chimney with me Charlie Yuletide
cheer with some cruel prank calls
sexual tension and suryya t go up slangs
yeah variety variety makes little sense
warranty you American girl I always
wanted this is a horror fun yeah I
didn't get any guesses Lady Gaga me
homicide is made in 1974 it's a horror
film yep and it's a color of the
spectrum plus spectrum is black
Christmas oh my god there we go
so it's just obviously that compared to
part two it's real close to Citizen Kane
I got to move Scott Wayne Baker's film
critic
oh come where the second the most second
movie is worse than the first and that's
home alone that's the only movie you can
think of that is the way the second one
is worse the only one we got in there
guys we got him look at that idea yeah I
need some help
brilliant the cheesiest thing I've
witnessed since lara croft rode the
shark to the surface of the
mediterranean brackets in a good way one
of the lines you'll get it if i say the
line smile and if you don't elf oh my
gosh thank the Lord you sit on a throne
of lies the first Christmas black comedy
for children oh well did we yeah but
it's definitely reviews are the same
thing we just glossed over the fact that
I got that immediately oh it was it was
more impressive what I did it now yours
on your mind on your mind and obviously
it sparked something so 65% on
tomorrow's
so with Oz gets like two can nobody go
back this Christmas classic and put some
more votes on home alone please
so fight fresh fast a bit with the iron
my brother's favorite yeah
[Applause]
Merry Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]